le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
depuis 2010 la réunion est inscrite au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité du
littoral jusqu'au quart des cirques
l'île abrite des trésors de biodiversité
à l'occasion de la 12e édition de la
fête de la nature
le public pourra découvrir une vingtaine
de ces lieux sur le terrain gibbs et
conservateurs préparent l'événement
[Musique]
e
on va arriver ici
derniers préparatifs avant les visites
avec quelques difficultés de dernière
minute c'est à dire fatiha nous a donné
du fil à rotor mais en même temps c'est
ça fait partie du métier
mais là pour le coup pâtir
elle va transformer attendu voilà comme
une vingtaine d'autres sites de l'île le
temps sera mise à l'honneur pour la 12e
édition de la fête de la nature une
occasion pour le public de découvrir la
richesse de la biodiversité réunionnaise
dans un premier temps pour la
préparation on va confronter donc nos
supports pédagogiques à la réalité et
c'est d'autant plus important que la
réalité elle a fortement changé par
rapport à faty re donc déjà on va
confronter un support pédagogique et
puis après on va voir si la
praticabilité des linéaires conre
parcours habituellement en tant que
conservateur c'est à nicolas et son
équipe que revient la tâche d'animer le
site lors de l'événement et les
difficultés notamment rien son
enthousiasme
l'objectif de la fête de la nation cette
arrivée fait rêver faire réagir ses plus
beaux métiers du monde
vraiment la chance un quelque part c'est
vrai on est sur le terrain
on voit la nature s'exprimer c'est un
beau métier et ce qui est encore plus
beau c'est de partager pièce que tu as
trouvé une paire d'antennes d'accord ont
regardé nombre de parts
ok les piérides indigènes migrateurs
très basse altitude a donc les étangs
les celui la connaissance que je peux
acquérir avec avec mes collègues 1 et il
faut pour la garder je vais diffuser
mais tous des passeurs
pour cette édition de la fête de la
nature celle infiniment petit qui est
mise à l'honneur le thème très difficile
mais c'est possible avec des méthodes et
des outils pédagogiques il faut des
boîtes loupes eux pouvoir l'infiniment
petit qui est pas directement visibles
on voit l'instant mais les deux millions
d'années d'histoire naturelle qui au qui
ont expliqué cet instant là on le voit
pas du battant des lames sommet des
montagnes tous les écosystèmes de l'île
sont passés au peigne fin
enfin j'ai pas mis dedans la bave ils
braquent les classiques dans la forêt
des hauts de mauvers autre paysage
autres espèces à découvrir sa dont tu
parlais de zones marines le verbe qu'on
sait pas c'est quoi une autre manif dans
ce milieu très préservée même les
conservateurs peuvent être encore
surpris par leur trouvaille qui si
beaucoup d'un seul coup on va retrouver
aussi anciennement aussi les oiseaux
forestiers et surtout une fleur une
flore qui est assez riche quand même
donc et on a la chance ici de retrouver
six à sept variétés de mar où donc sont
des arbres endémiques
on ne retrouve nulle part ailleurs que
sur l'île
ici une visite de trois heures sera
proposé au public avec un guide et des
supports explicatifs pour mieux
comprendre l'environnement qui les
entoure
on va aller à la découverte des espèces
aux abords de la piste expliqué un peu
ce qu'on fait en tant que
conservatoire des espaces naturels
présenter les espèces
s'ils trouvent à la fois donc phone est
plutôt flou accompagnés par les guident
le public pourra entrevoir le monde
secret caché derrière les feuillages
savez quand on va dans la nature on
n'arrive pas de manière furtive à
observer tout ce qui se passe autour de
nous et il est important aujourd'hui
d'apporter un regard différent
elle regarde beaucoup plus accentué sur
toutes les petites bêtes que nous
trouverons en milieu naturel et c'est
vrai ce que nous on attend c'est que les
réunionnais soient de plus en plus
sensibilisés à la protection de la
nature à notre environnement et à tout
ce qui compose cet environnement
notamment la biodiversité dont nous en
sommes très fiers à la réunion
[Musique]
il a fait de la nature est un événement
national qui a pour but de valoriser les
espaces naturels et de sensibiliser le
public à leur protection
elle se déroule du 11 au 15 mai à la
réunion une vingtaine de sites ont été
ciblés pour l'événement aux quatre coins
de l'île des visites guidées supports
pédagogiques qui sont proposés pour plus
d'information ou pour réserver contacter
le 02 62 97 59 59 ou rendez vous sur le
site du département au
www.desjardins.com 4 point fr
[Musique]
on va baisser si le madec j'ai 32 ans je
viens de saint denis
plus exactement vers le quartier de
canon je ne trouvais pas du tout dedans
mon domaine donc à la réunion et donc du
coup j'ai décidé de me réorienter et
puis j'ai tenté l aventure disney je
suis recrutement disney tout simplement
déjà c'est la magie disney et le cadre
est agréable et puis de faire rêver les
gens comme moi j'aimerais bien l'arrivée
donc voilà c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
ça à la réunion c'est vrai qu'on est
quand même assez ouvert puisque on a un
mélange culturel de religion mais c'est
vrai que là c'est une autre façon de
voir la multiculturalité aider des gens
et puis c'est voyager hors des leçons
sur la même un seul endroit précis ni
heureuse s'il est heureuse et elle
espère justement pouvoir continuer son
chemin à 10 mais pourquoi pas
[Musique]